foreign
you know with Daredevil getting another
TV series featuring Jessica Jones and
probably some of the other Defenders era
characters coming back I can't help but
Wonder when's punishment time John
bernthal's portrayal of the character
was a fan favorite and one of the most
enjoyable things to come out of that
little branch of the MCU maybe I went on
record as saying I didn't totally love
the writing in his solo show but
Bernthal was perfect and I can't wait
for him to return to the character but
until then we're feeling a Big Punisher
content drought
I'm a thirsty man at death's door
desperate for just a few drops of skull
vest wearing Revenge really the only
thing I have to come for me in this
trying time is to revisit the older
Punisher live action outings seeing as
how I felt the Netflix show left
something to be desired outside of its
Stellar casting I want to go digging
through these and see if any of the
three of them gave me the kind of
Punisher adaptation I was looking for
one of these is bound to get something
right especially since they're such
wildly different films and made in such
different ages for comic book movies
join me as we tear into three
generations of Frank Castle Cinema and
figure out which one best suits the
tastes of myself a very particular fan
of the character what was the best
Punisher movie
[Music]
the 80s wasn't exactly the highlight of
Marvel's cinematic Saga with such lovely
entries as the original Punisher red
Sonia and
Howard the Duck
it's funny to me how the second
theatrically released mainstream Marvel
movie adaptation had to be that and the
third was this you couldn't get any more
polar opposite if you tried this was
around the time of Donner's Superman
Trilogy and Burton's Batman movies and
you'd think bigger characters like
Spider-Man or Captain America would get
some kind of big budget Hollywood
treatment
sure there were plans but nothing
finalized in this decade I guess the
Punisher just fit the world of the 80s
more it's a dark cynical violent story
with no clear hero and lots of guns the
elevator pitch was probably like imagine
Death Wish meets The Godfather and it
got the stamp of approval before they
even knew it was from those
silly comic Rags for dumb babies that
would never be profitable in theaters
Dolph Lundgren may not have been my
first choice to play Frank Castle but
once you see him in the role it's like
damn that guy really looks like Frank
Castle at least Circa the 1980s it's
like he leapt right off the page to stab
you
what's fascinating about this movie to
me is that considering the time period
the budget the stigma around comic book
characters and how easy this particular
character is to screw up
this one's a really solid first try at
adapting The Punisher it's got plenty of
flaws primarily a very start and stop
pacing in some scenes that tend to lose
my interest but the actual punisherness
of it all has been well established the
movie lights up when he's around the way
he fights has a lot of variety and
creativity and sometimes his wacky
schemes to catch the bad guys end up
being really convoluted and excessive
but that's the charm he's like a
competent and successful Wily coyote in
a world full of roadrunners this movie's
got the right amount of cheesiness that
I feel like he should be wearing the
skull vest and the white boots and
gloves in this script that wouldn't have
been out of place at all this is already
in the realm of violent and campy it's
baffling to me that they'd stop so short
of fully committing by omitting the
costume it even has some wacky comic
relief Side characters like shake a guy
who hangs out with Frank Castle in the
sewers and only speaks in Rhymes hey
they will and all for not the children
will be sold by the slave trade
this is a result of your five-year
killing spree
why do we draw the line at the logo on
his shirt instead the skull is just on
the tip of punisher's knives which isn't
nearly as cool Punisher 1989 however
avoided the rookie mistake of spending
too much time focusing on the particular
criminals that killed the castle family
as the main villains instead that guy
gets got in the first five minutes of
the movie I actually prefer how
impersonal punisher's anti-crime wave is
he doesn't want revenge on anyone in
particular just like whoever he thinks
has it coming he's like an 80s slasher
villain in that way Jason Voorhees isn't
hunting the teenage Camp counselors that
let him drown as a child he's just mad
at anyone who even vaguely reminds him
of them the main focus of the movie is
taking on New York's biggest gang in
addition to a branch of the Yakuza that
has decided to start a turf war with
them so the Punisher is just caught in
the middle of both groups I think the
Yakuza leader lady Tanaka is a really
cool villain and a nice change of pace
from the usual Wise Guys in business
suits that Frank has to battle I just
wish he had more direct confrontations
with her because she's more of an
antagonist for the other Crime Boss
Gianni Franco that's a Punisher villain
name if I've ever heard one his name
could just be crimbo italiani Frank
Castle is portrayed as being like kind
of weird and smelly and insane he lives
in the sewers he's got permanent five
o'clock shadow people who used to know
him and trust him are now ashamed of
what he's become Lundgren's take on
Castle is a guy just waiting to finally
get capped in battle he's so reckless in
every mission is a suicide mission for
him but he's just too damn good and
keeps making it out alive his old
partner confronts him when he's briefly
taken into custody and he just shuts him
out like he's dead set on going out
there and getting himself killed
but you gotta talk to me man let me in
later in the movie he even goes out of
his way to reject wearing body armor
something The Punisher doesn't normally
do here just in case
have it your way
you're eager to lose but he never does
that's kind of a cool spin on it it
would have been really easy for the
movie to forget he was originally
introduced as a villain in the comics
and just go America hell yeah kill them
all Frank you're the best painting him
is totally justified loses the moral
grayness of the character and starts to
get to like mob mentality Anarchy
Society has completely broken down if
the Punisher is a role model and this
movie thankfully kept that in mind
without also being too preachy about it
the movie doesn't really pick his side
at all he's fully aware that he's doing
something wrong when the lead crime
boss's son Tommy pulls a gun on Frank he
lets the scene play out either willing
to be killed by someone he considers
innocent and finally get his sweet
release we're seeing that little Tommy
here doesn't have that same ruthlessness
and revenge in his heart when Tommy
can't kill him Frank is like yeah you're
a good person so you didn't give into
Revenge you're a good boy Tommy
grow up to be a good man because if not
I'll be waiting this is a subtle but
clever admittance that he doesn't really
think of himself as a good person it's
just a great scene all around and
perfectly caps off the whole story this
is an example of one of my five rules
for writing good Punisher stories Frank
Castle is not a morally upright hero guy
sure the people he kills are generally
pretty terrible and the world probably
is better off without them but the story
can't endorse what he does because for
all intents and purposes he is a highly
prolific serial killer his choice of
victim just happens to be skilled
criminals and other Killers rather than
like women who look vaguely like his mom
or something but scenes like that last
one show that he's not a completely
heartless and evil person a good
Punisher story can help us understand
his motivations but also make sure that
we know he's deeply flawed he's the
tiniest bit Noble in the right moment
but his personal mission is also very
selfish and self-destructive and to an
extent he's a pretty sick man like he
doesn't need to go around tying dudes
intestines to trees or giving his
girlfriend Elektra bronzed human heart
that he cut out of a Crime Boss that
stuff's wacky and over the top and too
far chill out Frank this writing line of
being a twisted maniac and
kind of a hero sort of but not really is
what makes the character so divisive but
it's also what makes him interesting and
complex to me at least I think anyone
who says the Punisher is a flat
character just doesn't know what they're
talking about however a lot of these
tend to avoid delving too deep in
Frank's character and spend most of
their time piddling around with various
crime bosses and their interpersonal
drama as the punishment approaches like
that moon in the Zelda game coming to
crush all their meaningless quibbles
like a colony of ants under a boot this
brings us to
oh the [__] goddamn heater I'm gonna
lose my
[Music]
the first Punisher film in a post-garth
Ennis world
even back then they were having to reign
in his childish ideas and blind
superhero hatred like bumpos body fat
being used to smother the Russian to
death or half the storyline being about
making Wolverine and Daredevil look
incompetent pathetic The Punisher filmed
from 2004 decided to go back to the
origin story and dip its toes a little
bit further into Comic bookie territory
with some actual moments adapted
straight from the books
some characters from the Marvel Knights
comic even appear and then even finally
partially embracing the aesthetic of
punisher's signature look unfortunately
this particular variant of his logo has
been ruined by crazy fake fans over the
years who don't know anything about the
character other than uh yeah big dude
with a gun it's okay though it's been
drawn like a billion different ways that
look much cooler so you can just look
for Merch of those if you don't want
people side eyeing you in public
as badly they'll still do it of course
but maybe less it was a gift from his
son that's weird and doesn't make sense
I mean maybe if he was like a metal head
Marine that went to Slipknot and Gwar
concerts like my dad it didn't make
sense but I just can't imagine Frank
Castle ever like
casually wearing this shirt to the
grocery store
who's basically just a dark Omen that
little uh not Frank Jr here was going to
get watermelon by a pickup truck maybe
the shirt is cursed and he should have
just burned it to save his family
splatter spree
anyway in this universe Frank Castle is
an undercover FBI agent that runs sting
operations against the mob one day a
routine Mission results in the death of
the son of notorious Maniac John
Travolta I mean Howard Saint with
vengeance being a particularly big theme
of this story if you've noticed the
saint crime family retaliated against
agent castle by wiping out not just his
family but his entire lineage every
branch of his family tree is killed at a
castle family reunion his aunts his
uncles his parents his cousins his
nieces and nephews
so excessive just how many family
members are killed all at once like this
is Uchiha Clan levels of Massacre
ironically as cartoonishly over the top
as this is I find it way less disturbing
than punisher's comic origin turning the
death of Frank Castle's family into a
big epic multi-man gun battle turned
high impact car chase with brawling and
headbutts and shooting and Bam
just sucks the terror out of it now it
doesn't feel like this random awful
thing that could have happened to just
anyone it was a more personal mission of
revenge against Frank specifically that
like escalated to the point of being
ridiculous that end we don't really get
to know any of these family members at
length before this happens so they're
just scores of NPCs that we only really
feel bad about because we know they're
somehow related to Frank you'd think in
a movie this long they try to flesh out
more of these characters but that run
time's devoted to the middle section of
the movie where long stretches of
nothing really interesting happens one
of the major reasons I never really love
the 2004 Punisher movie was because I
always felt the glacial pacing killed a
lot of my hype it's cool that so many
characters from the Marvel Knights book
made it here those being punishers
quirky Trio of Neighbors in his
apartment building but I feel like too
much emphasis was placed on them in an
attempt to humanize the stonehearted
murder fella but at least that wasn't in
vain if there's anything this movie can
claim to have over the other two it's
that they did a really decent job of
making the Punisher of all people seem
like a likable guy that isn't completely
[__] terrifying Thomas Jane portrays
The Punisher with a more understated
sadness than an unbridled rage he's like
a broken man that has nothing left and
no reason to smile and you do feel for
him it's nice having the neighbors reach
out to him and he's like not really
receptive to the pleasantries but he's
polite enough to go along with it if
there's any version of the character
that had the tiniest shred of like
heroism and honor it's this one that
being said he's still solid when he's
doing his Punisher thing it's just a
small segment of the movie by comparison
hey he's even got the vest from Punisher
year one rather than Frank and his full
outfit chasing down criminals and
putting a boot down the collective
throat of organized crime a lot of this
movie veers off into the somewhat
ridiculous territory of him
psychologically terrorizing Howard saint
by gaslighting him with like
elaborate pranks he stole Howard Saints
wife's car and parked in front of a
hotel and put down a fake fire hydrant
and called the parking commission to get
parking tickets on her car and then
returned her car and then planted her
earrings on Howard Saints gay best
friend's bed so Howard Saint would
assume that his wife was having an
affair with his friend who he didn't
know was gay but also Frank took
pictures of the friend posing as an
anonymous blackmailer to also
orchestrate the areas that he would go
to further implicate him with the wife
also there's a deleted scene where I'm
pretty sure Frank makes a veiled
homophobic remark and uh
I'm gonna go smoke some cigarettes
oh smoke
uh this really is based on Garth and his
comics
this is a lot of [__] and at a certain
point I feel like it would make more
sense to just blow them all up with an
RPG or something but the point was to
make Howard Saint feel like his life was
blowing up and trick him into killing
the people he loved most I get what they
were going for and Punisher is one for
some really over elaborate plans to get
the bad guy but after a while this just
feels like Overkill and it was a lot
less fun to watch than him rolling
through a guy's house with a bulldozer
or something more blunt and stupid the
actual action scenes are really cool
when they finally do get around to them
the battle with the Russian has to be
like top five comic book movie fights
though it's just so much fun Frank
Castle's got a cool souped up muscle car
with extra armor he's got all kinds of
traps and secret weapons in his
apartment and he's pretty handy with a
shotgun when the time comes
there's just so much slow introspective
down time between but like for
characters that aren't Frank which is
weird do we need this scene where a
random Hitman comes into the diner and
intimidatingly plays guitar at The
Punisher in a slow Moody scene like it
was a Western in fact a lot of this
movie's Vibes are like a western with
these slow tense standoffs between him
and the bad guys and just the general
sound of the score
yeah
that guy that blew up off screen becomes
jigsaw in the PS2 game and steals an
Iron Man suit from Stark Industries
though I will commend this movie for not
just trying to be mindless violence it
was going for something and uh
successfulness is kind of like you know
up to your personal interpretation the
opposite end of the spectrum where it's
just shooting in blood without any
substance would be just as irritating
surely the next movie would find a happy
medium right
you know what before we get to that
let's give an honorary mention to Thomas
Jane's second live-action outing which
of course he did because he's actually a
really huge fan of the character
[Music]
okay yes technically this one is an
unlicensed fan film but it was produced
by a lot of official people working in
Hollywood and the cast includes yes
Thomas Jane and also
it's Ron Perlman it was one of several
unofficial High budget high production
value fan projects under the bootleg
Universe label produced by ADI Shankar
who you might know from his work on
dread one of the kick-assist movies ever
made and for an unofficial project it's
pretty solid the short centers on Frank
wandering into a bad neighborhood where
everyone lives in fear of the local gang
however I don't exactly Vibe with the
choice to have him be all reluctant to
help any of these people until the very
last minute he ignores in-progress
crimes to just get his laundry done keep
his head down and get a drink he's his
own great power great responsibility
Mantra albeit more drastic and twisted
if you have the power to shotgun someone
you should
the idea of him just neglecting to help
everyone out there getting brutalized
feels off and conflicts with my other
rule for writing good Punisher I think a
crutch some writers use to adapt him as
having him feel conflicted about his
role as a vigilante and have him trying
and failing to quit being a killer this
is a pretty standard generic character
conflict that we've seen a million times
with a million movie tough guys every
time I try to get out they just keep
pulling me back in and so on and so
forth he just needed his depressed I'm
done with that life beard but one of the
things I always liked about the
character in the comics was his singular
focus and extreme dedication to his
cause he's like the opposite end of
Batman who is equally as upright in his
principles about never killing both of
these guys are interesting when they're
super determined to do things their way
whatever the cost
but for some reason we keep getting
movies where Batman is constantly
killing people and Punisher movies where
he's so reluctant to kill what the hell
happened can these characters like act
like themselves and not like each other
please
even in spite of this Thomas Jane gives
a strong performance again and the short
is pretty stylish I just find myself
distracted by the lack of original score
because speaking of Batman all of this
is music from The Dark Knight soundtrack
also that bottle of Jack Daniels is made
of adamantium my God
it's not a perfect send-off to Jane's
take on Punisher but it's still nice to
see him again after it seemed pretty
certain he was a one-and-done deal I
like that skull logo better than his
other one
the skull is still on his vest but it's
barely visible
it looks fine on the poster but in the
movie it's like five percent opacity
what were they embarrassed again did
they think it looked too silly
cowardice also like why would you get
self-conscious about that sort of thing
in this movie
oh for [__] sake it's like everyone
wants to adapt different parts of the
Garth and his books usually just the
quirky Side characters and foul-mouthed
villains and the dark comedy tone except
they neglect the most interesting part
the characterization of Frank Castle the
book is a really deep dive into the mind
and psychology of Frank Castle and he's
the central component of the emotional
core of that story like it's a big
character study really we understand his
trauma his rage his history in the war
his childhood his personal ideology his
thought process behind his strategies
his philosophy on his own existence his
insecurities about the life he's chosen
for himself and his longing for a better
one where he feels more whole as a
person
and this is Frank Castle is a truly deep
and fascinating character
you know fascinating in the same way as
like Hannibal Lecter or Darth Vader
where you know he's crazy and clearly
bad but you understand how he got there
and he's so charismatic and badass that
he's fun to watch he's just such a
well-fleshed out character in these
books and yet the three different times
these Comics have been adapted they
didn't really go for any of that Thomas
Jane isn't written to be nearly as
obsessed and twisted Ray Stevenson is
barely a character at all and the movie
forgets he exists half the time and with
John bernthal's Punisher they opted to
ride him more like an eternally
conflicted Fusion of Jason Bourne and
Wolverine so he'd be more relatable
repeating the same character Arc three
times is more relatable I often feel
like recent movie discourse confuses
character depth with how often does he
quip or how relatable is he Punisher
doesn't need to be a down-to-earth
relatable guy to be interesting but he
also doesn't need to be like a stoic
emotionless zombie that's treated more
like an entity than a real character I'm
going to be saying all of this again in
a few years when they finally make that
Spawn movie that barely has spawn in it
all that being said I don't love this
movie's take on Frank that much we skim
over the origin this time and now
Frank's been at large for a few years
doing his thing until one night he
accidentally punishes an undercover cop
and creates a nemesis in jigsaw
uh who like by decades predates the
villain played by Tobin Bell a criminal
that Frank horrifically deforms but
accidentally leaves alive so jigsaw is
putting together a huge Revenge plot and
Frank's just sort of moping around about
hitting an unintended Target so he's
heavily considering hanging up the vest
but he just loves punishing too damn
much
plus the family of the Dead undercover
cop is now in jigsaw's sights for a
Revenge so Frank has to take on the
uncomfortable job of being a protector
instead of just mashed potatoing people
jigsaw is the big standout of this one
he's the best villain these movies have
had yet he's just so cartoonishly evil
and vile and the Practical makeup for
his facial scars looked really good
it's so chilling and his face gives you
a slasher villain Vibes like Freddy
Krueger
[Music]
[__] you this version of Frank is
underdeveloped and his two sidekicks
micro and Carlos barely get any screen
time either
I think he could have devoted a lot more
time to them in particular the story of
how micro became Frank's armorer could
have been fun to adapt and the idea of
Carlos a former criminal teaming up with
the Punisher in itself is a great
concept because it challenges his idea
that a lot of these gang members can't
be reformed this guy could have been
such a huge factor in this movie
but instead that stuff is pushed to the
Wayside for jigsaw and his brother just
being Looney together if there's
something I can certainly praise about
this one it's that this movie finally
Wades into the murky Waters or
punisher's opinion on police and
systemic corruption it's faint but it's
there something that often gets ignored
about the character is that he's
critical of the police thinking they're
serving a corrupt justice system or they
themselves are too corrupt to get
anything done Punisher wouldn't be the
Punisher if he thought the police were
doing their jobs properly in the comics
he also scoffs at the idea of them
idolizing him because it's fundamentally
hypocritical and dangerous for them to
think that way that's another one of
those Punisher adaptation rules I have
and it's weird that only this one took
the time to address that considering how
much everything else in this movie is a
big cartoon although they fumble The
Landing a little bit this movie kind of
loses the plot on murderous Vigilantes
being a bad thing and basically absolves
Frank of all guilt at the End by going
ah you're good no one's mad at you and
all the police characters in the movie
are like reluctantly helping him out
constantly which the movie doesn't
acknowledge as being extremely bad
it's more just played with like an irony
and a smirk like oh man
it's crazy that they're helping the
Punisher they should be not doing that
throwing you a tip now and against one
thing
password of the crime database Etc but
letting you go so
you know so they lose points for all
that [__] maybe Punisher himself isn't
as much of a focus as I'd have liked him
to be but the tone is closer in this to
what I would want it's got crazy bad
guys it's dark but also silly and like
allows itself to have fun and the only
part of the movie Taken deadly serious
is the Punisher himself he shouldn't be
quipping or being an incompetent fool
but the stuff around him is allowed to
be funny plus the fight scenes afford
themselves some excessiveness that's
fitting for the character sometimes it
goes overboard and it's just really dumb
but their head was in the right place
I just wish it was all in service of a
stronger story and better characters
Warzone seems to be a confused movie
that isn't entirely sure what it wants
to say about Frank so his inclusion is
muddled and it comes across like a more
generic action movie with the by the
book cop and the Loose Cannon who plays
by his own rules
with the benefit of existing in a world
such as the MCU future Punisher movies
can drop the effort to be so grounded
with their stories and villains I like
to think one of these could feel more
like smoke and Aces or bullet train
where there's like a whole cast of weird
and eccentric bad guys with their own
gimmicks and personas all coming out of
the woodwork to kill the Punisher I want
to see Punisher versus guys like
Bullseye Bushwacker Barracuda someone
else with a B name or even some weirder
ones like the Jackal [__] let's have
Punisher hang out with Spider-Man that's
never been done before and I guess Tom
Holland and John Bernthal are buddies so
the most fun Punisher story lines or
stuff like him trying to assassinate
Norman Osborne and being hunted by the
Sentry or him stealing an old war
machine suit to go try and create peace
in the Middle East or when he was on a
team with Deadpool Ghost Rider and Venom
him and Venom have a lot in common
actually
two Spider-Man villains with complex
morals that got popular enough to just
become solo characters and turn into
anti-heroes all three of these movies
checked a few marks for me but none of
them quite got the whole list and
neither did the TV series I guess the
only Punisher adaptation to do all of
the stuff I wanted was the video game
and that game kicks ass go watch my
video on it I know it's really picky to
have such excessive criteria for this
character and even the source material
sometimes fails to hit those marks but I
think if you find the winning
combination of those ingredients it
makes for an incredibly compelling
character that has some of my favorite
comic stories it's just that he's harder
than most to get totally right it's like
out Batman Superman and Spider-Man have
had their own fair share of bad
adaptations but when you get it right
it's a really satisfying end result I
have a sense that Hollywood wants to
make this character work but have this
air of discomfort around the more
unpleasant reality that can stigmatize
the character so they grounded two far
into the real world to try to unpack all
of this and it stops being as fun as it
could be or they go too silly with it
and it becomes tone deaf
okay
the politics of it are an inevitability
he's an angry white man with a gun
taking the law on his own hands he's a
traumatized veteran who was forgotten by
his country he's in pursuit of a mission
fueled by a law system completely broken
down by corruption
these are things you have to address but
you can also have a little fun with it
too because it's a comic book
it can handle these messy real world
issues that are inherently built into
the story while also being an
adventurous comic book story these are
not mutually exclusive Batman has been
pulling that off for decades his newest
movie addresses in-cell conspiracy nuts
planning acts of domestic terrorism and
has scenes of him solving funny riddles
on a card and wearing bulletproof super
armor and making out with his girlfriend
that likes to dress up as a cat I think
the Punisher deserves the same kind of
efforts from a movie or a TV show
adaptation but a show about comic Acura
Punisher would get boring and repetitive
he's just killing criminals over and
over yes and you can make a fun series
about a crazy sad guy going on a Revenge
Rampage against hundreds of armed
criminals we're on John Wick 4. yes you
can make a show about a serial killer
vigilante that's disconnected from his
Humanity we're on season 11 of Dexter if
you're one of those guys that comment
that on my review of the Netflix series
I'm sorry but you have a profound lack
of imagination and should slap yourself
for being so reductive to make such a
bad point you can make any premise sound
bad if you phrase it like that
so it's just some guy with a bad costume
catching lunatics at every movie it's
just a war in space that keeps going
how can the guy finding old magic
treasure not get repetitive after one
movie
slap yourself harder you're stupid
anyway Dexter as John Wick with bullet
train villains is my elevator pitch to
get this series back on the right track
but who knows maybe they'll just adapt
Franken castle and call it a day as for
what's the best Punisher movie uh uh it
was a PS2 game I always get mad at
YouTube for not putting my videos in the
subscription box because people will
comment finally Xavier uploads again
after all these years
not knowing three other videos came out
within the last month already so maybe
that stupid Bell icon thing will help
you remember I exist if you want other
ways to support the channel you can
always go hit up that patreon for early
videos and exclusive stuff because it's
just a dollar I'm not kidding it's only
one dollar Isn't that cool if everyone
who watched this video donated one
dollar a month I'd be able to afford a
house for myself so that would be that
would be really cool you can also check
out our merch on T public or just buy
some of my random stuff on eBay I have a
pretty substantial collection of old
toys that are still in the box in
perfect condition so go take a look in
case you find something you like and
lastly since this is a YouTube video and
you probably play fortnite drop my
Creator quote Xavier GM next time you
buy a silly dance or cool character skin
really helps me out
see you next time
[Music]
foreign